Québécois, l'effort collectif,
mais soulagé de pouvoir annoncer
des nouvelles assez bonnes.
Docteur Cécile Tremblay est avec
nous. Bonsoir Docteur Tremblay.
Les nouvelles étaient bonnes
quand même?
- Oui, les nouvelles étaient
bonnes parce que le plan est
raisonnable et que la situation
épidémiologique ne permet de
faire ce déconfinement.
- On va regarder ensemble les
dates : l'28 mai, c'est la
première date importante devant
nous. Fin du couvre-feu, c'est
terminé.
Terrasses des restaurants, on
les retrouverait. Huit personnes
à l'extérieur, on pourra faire
des petits rassemblements
familiaux. SP et sport, jusqu'à
2500 personnes. Ce sont dans des
endroits où on a des places
désignées. On pense au Centre
Bell par exemple, si les Indiens
traversent les premiers matchs
avec les Leafs. Vous n'avez pas
de problème avec ça?
- Dans la mesure où ils ont
précisé que c'est par section de
250 personnes. On essaie encore
de limiter les attroupements et
les possibilités de
contamination. Ça me semble
raisonnable dans les très grands
espaces.
- En juin, on ajoute les
terrasses des bars. Les sports
et loisirs extérieurs, on pense
aux saccades, etc. 25 personnes.
Ça, c'est la continuation
logique.
- Oui. Tout ce qui est extérieur
n'est pas problématique, parce
qu'on sait qu'à l'extérieur, le
degré de contagion est beaucoup
moindre. Donc ça nous permet,
ces étapes nous permettent
d'accumuler encore plus de monde
vacciner pendant ce temps pour
se rendre aux prochaines étapes.
- Et de manière générale,
parallèle à ça, ce sont des
dates qui s'appliquent partout
sur le territoire québécois.
Mais on dit que d'ici la fin
maie, la plupart des régions a
dit Monsieur Legault seront en
somme orange. Donc les gyms vont
rouvrir, etc. On est rendu là
d'après vous?
- Oui, parce qu'on voit le
nombre des cas baisser de façon
systématique depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines. Un élément
important était que la tendance
se maintient, que ce soit pas
juste quelque chose d'une
semaine. Les installations sont
en baisse et les dessins sont
malheureusement toujours autour
de huit à 10 cas par jour, mais
quand même, la situation
épidémiologique montre qu'il y a
moins de transmission
communautaire.
- Et on le voit, on est sous le
seuil des 500 hospitalisations à
484. Appareil date en dernier,
on était à 1438 je crois. Ou en
tout cas autour de ça. Donc
c'est un autre monde. Donc ça,
Docteur Tremblay, vous allez
dire que c'est une évidence,
mais la vaccination, ça
fonctionne.
- Oui et on est tellement
chanceux... on n'est pas chancex
d'avoir eu une pandémie, mais on
est chanceux d'avoir eu des
vaccins qui ont été développés
très rapidement et qui ont une
efficacité de 95 %. Ça, c'est le
fruit de la science du travail
de beaucoup de gens mais ça
aurait pu ne pas être. Ayant ces
outils en main, ce qui nous
permet de sortir de la pandémie.
- Parlant de la vaccination,
parce que j'ai gardé la dernière
pour après. Monsieur Legault de.
Je, Faillon l'actuel. On est à
60,3 % de la population adulte,
donc 18 ans et plus et deuxième,
c'est à peu près 4,7 %.
L'objectif a pour la fin août,
75 % de de relations de se
- Will Pointe Lepreau c'est
cette facilement facilement,
leur première T. Après Althaus
complètement
dans la mesure où on a tous nos
vaccins et que les gens ont eu
leur première dose, on peut
rapprocher la deuxième dose. On
va pouvoir en vacciner pendant
tout l'été.
- J'ouvre une parenthèse sur la
deuxième dose. On reçoit encore
énormément de questions des gens
qui ont reçu l'AstraZeneca. Il
se demande : est-ce que je
devrais prendre ou pas comme
deuxième dose l'AstraZeneca?
- Ce qu'on se rend compte, c'est
que les maladies rares qui sont
arrivées avec AstraZeneca, les
thromboses, sont arrivés dans la
majorité des cas à la première
dose. Autrement dit, quand les
gens l'ont reçu une fois et qui
n'ont pas fait des réactions,
ils ne vont pas en faire à la
deuxième dose. Le risque était
déjà minime. Il est encore plus
à la deuxième dose. Je m'en
priverai pas de le recevoir.
- Si on peut le recevoir, si on
a pas eu de problème, il y a pas
de problème pour la deuxième
dose. Le risque est
insignifiant. Par ailleurs, si
quelqu'un veut vraiment pas
l'AstraZeneca, laisse penser
maintenant si on peut avoir une
deuxième dose de Pfizer?
- Les données sont pas encore
publiées, mais on pense qu'il y
aura pas de problème. De toute
façon, on aura pas assez
d'AstraZeneca pour vacciner les
deuxième dose. Alors on pense
théoriquement d'un point de vue
scientifique il n'y a pas
vraiment de raison de penser que
ça ne fonctionnerait pas.
- Mais si je prends, admettons
que j'ai eu l'AstraZeneca, je
prends l'Pfaïzeur comme deuxième
dose, est-ce que je devrais
prendre une troisième dose de
Pfaïzeur qui serais ma deuxième
dose de Pfaïzeur?
- Fort probablement pas, parce
que l'idée de la deuxième dose
est de rehausser l'effet de la
première dose. On a monté les
anticorps quand on a reste la
première dose et le deuxième
vaccin réveille les cellules
mémoires qui ont été développées
lors de la première dose pour
elle-même produisent les
anticorps. Donc il y aurait pas
nécessité d'avoir une troisième
dose à moins qu'on ait affaire à
un invariant.
- Donc même si on change de la
famille des vaccins, on aura pas
besoin d'en ajouter une deuxième
sur la deuxième. Le masque,
Monsieur Legault a dit : d'ici
la fin d'août, on est arrivé au
seuil de 75 % de la population
de 12 ans et plus qui ont les
deux vaccins au Québec, on
pourra enlever le masque. Vous
êtes d'accord avec ça. To
- bien, oui, dans la mesure où
quand les gens ont reçu lors de
dose de vaccin, ils sont quand
même protégés à plus de 95 %.
Ici on est de plus en plus déjà
assez regroupé avec deux doses
de vaccin, les gens sont
protégés, ils n'auront pas
besoin de masque entre eux. Ceci
dit, voyons où on n'en est rendu
à la fin houe et si on a atteint
notre 75 %. Il faut toujours
avoir en tête les variantes
possibles qui pourraient émerger
d'ailleurs et venir... juste avt
de dire : à la fin du mois, tout
est fini, il n'y a plus de
pandémie, je me garderai une
petite réserve. Ce garde une
petite réserve également
dépensée par les ça va faire un
an et demi, c'est l'entrevue la
plus agréable.
- Oui.
- C'est toujours agréable, même
comprenez ce que je, c'est
l'entrevue la plus lumineuse.
Ensuite on a vraiment raison de
croire qu'on ressort de la
pandémie et c'est grâce à la
participation et la contribution
de tous les Québécois et les
Québécoises, mais tous les
efforts qui ont été mis jusqu'à
présent. Le confinement a
contribué à ce qu'on puisse...
- quand on va parler de la
pandémie à l'échelle
internationale, il va falloir
regarder cette solidarité en